en este vídeo vamos a multiplicar mono
mios
déjenme darles un ejemplo de mono mío 4x
cuadrada este es un mono mío porque
bueno mono significa uno que se refiere
al número de términos así que este 4x
cuadrada es un término todo esto es un
solo término vamos a estar trabajando
con cosas como esta y con que no
estaremos trabajando bueno qué tal 4 x
cuadrada + 5 x cuántos términos hay aquí
4x cuadrada es el primer término y 5x es
el segundo término así que esto no es un
mono mío está en realidad se llama
binomio porque vi significados como tu
bicicleta por ejemplo que tiene dos
ruedas así que puedes avanzar a los
siguientes vídeos y ya estás listo para
los binomios pero ahora vamos a estar
trabajando con la multiplicación de mono
mios así que para el final de este vídeo
que debería resultar muy fácil
multiplicar este mono mió 5x cuadrada
por este mono mió 4x 6a
y en realidad te voy a dar la respuesta
justo aquí y luego vamos a ir lentamente
revisando algunas preguntas que nos van
a explicar el porqué de esto y la
respuesta es 20 x a la octava potencia
20 x a la octava potencia mira eso y ver
si puedes encontrar un patrón que
hicimos con el 5 y con el 4 para obtener
20 y que hicimos con el 2 y el 6 para
obtener 8 esto va más allá de lo que
sabemos por ahora antes de que lo
revisemos vamos a recordar algunas
propiedades de los exponentes algunas
propiedades muy específicas que ya debes
haber visto si tenemos 5 al cuadrado
multiplicado por 5 a la cuarta potencia
a que es igual esto bueno si recuerdas
las propiedades de los exponentes y
vamos a hacer una revisión rápida
siempre sumamos los exponentes así que 5
al cuadrado multiplicado por 5 a la
cuarta potencia es igual a 5 elevado a
la sexta potencia y si tenemos 3 elevado
a la cuarta potencia por 3 elevado a la
quinta potencia bueno como siempre los
exponentes
459 esto es igual a 3 a la novena
potencia y la base que es 3 se queda
igual muy bien así que si recuerdas eso
ahora vamos realmente a comenzar a
multiplicar mono mios que es lo nuevo
para ti y lo que es nuevo aquí es que
vamos a tener variables involucradas en
esto entonces vamos a empezar con 2 mono
mios y el primer mono mío es 4x y el
segundo es simplemente equis y tengo un
4 y no tengo otro número por el que
tenga que multiplicarlo así que me queda
el 4 y puedo simplificar x por equis
esto es igual a equis cuadrada recuerda
que si tengo una variable que no tiene
exponente es como si tuviera un
exponente igual a 1 así que tengo x en
la primera potencia x x a la primera
potencia y suma mis exponentes como ya
lo explicamos antes y uno más uno es
igual a dos muy bien vamos a hacer otro
digamos 4 t por 3 t
bueno 4 por 3 es igual a 12 multiplico
mis coeficientes y luego deporte
nuevamente tengo que pensar que tengo 1
aquí y aquí y esto va a ser igual a t
cuadrada así que la respuesta va a ser
igual a 12 t cuadrada vamos a continuar
tenemos 4 p a la quinta potencia por 5 p
a la tercera potencia a que va a ser
igual esto bueno vas a notar un patrón
aquí y es que siempre multiplico mis
coeficientes 4 por 5 es igual a 20 y
siempre sumo a mis exponentes así que ve
a la quinta porque a la tercera es igual
a p a la octava potencia entonces
multiplico cuatro por cinco para obtener
20 y sumó 5 y 3 para obtener 8 y si en
realidad quieres entender esto vamos a
sumergirnos y descomponer 4p a la quinta
potencia puede escribirlo como 4 por p
por p por p por p por p es un 4 y 5 p es
y luego el segundo término lo puedo
escribir como 5 por p por p por p y lo
que voy a hacer es agrupar mis números
para que pueda trabajar con mis números
así que voy a escribir cuatro por cinco
al principio y luego tengo que ver
cuántas veces tengo y ponerlas todas
juntas así que tengo las primeras 5
y luego tengo otras tres
y puedo simplificar esta loca expresión
multiplicando el 4 por el 5 para obtener
el 20 y luego reescribiendo esto con un
exponente es lo hermoso de los
exponentes que podemos reescribir una
expresión como ésta simplemente como p
elevada a la octava potencia y puedes
ver que esto es lo que obtuvimos aquí
arriba al principio muy bien qué tal 5 y
a la sexta por menos 13 a la octava
potencia nuevamente multiplicamos los
coeficientes y sumamos los exponentes y
obtenemos una expresión simplificada
vamos a divertirnos un poco ya que
descubrimos el patrón vamos a
divertirnos un poco menos 9 por equis a
la quinta potencia por menos 3 por equis
a la potencia 107 y vamos a usar
paréntesis cuando tenemos expresiones
negativas si les hubiera mostrado esto
antes de este vídeo tal vez se hubieran
dicho dios mío no hay nada que pueda
hacer no hay manera pero ahora saben que
es tan simple como seguir las reglas
vamos a multiplicar los coeficientes
menos 9 x menos 3 es igual a 27
multiplicar 2 negativos es igual a
positivo y 9 por 3 es 27 y voy a sumar
mis potencias 5 + 107
es igual a 112 entonces ésta lo que
expresión que contiene 2 mono mios aquí
está el primero aquí está el segundo
cuando los multiplicamos obtenemos otro
mono vio que es 27 x a la potencia 112
les voy a dejar en suspenso y les voy a
mostrar un problema 5x a la tercera
potencia por 4x a la sexta potencia y
les voy a mostrar una respuesta
incorrecta tengo unos alumnos a los que
les pedí que hicieran esto y esta es la
respuesta incorrecta que me dieron 9 x a
la 18va potencia esto está completamente
mal porque se equivocaron que hicieron
mal quiero que lo piense en un momento
de que hemos estado hablando que
hicieron con el 5 y con el 4 para
obtener 9 y que debieron haber hecho
y que hicieron con el 3 y con el 6 para
obtener 18 y que es lo que debieron
haber hecho esto es la multiplicación de
mono mios